[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما سنخصصها اليوم للحديث
عن القمه في جده القمه العربيه وحضور
سوريا وعوده استلام سوريا لمقعدها فيها
وهذه هي العناوين
الاسد في جده للمشاركه في القمه هي مشاركه
رمزيه ام خطوات حقيقيه لانفتاح سوريا
اقليميا ودوليا
اكتمل النصاب عادت سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه بيد من تسويه ازماتها الرئيس
الاسد ام المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
اتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا لمقعدها
مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها مع استئناف الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها
بمنظماتنا نحن ممتنون ان كل الدول العربيه
الان موجوده في هذه القمه
انتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم السعوديه بدلت جهدها من اجل تحسين
الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري
سوريا لا يمكن ان تغيب عن اي تمارين
اذا مشاهدينا اكتمل النصاب سوريا عادت الى
القمه العربيه اثني عشر عاما من الغياب
ازمات وصعوبات كبيره مرت بها سوريا
والمنطقه سوريا العائده تفتح صفحه جديده
اليوم مع العالم العربي الذي سعى طويلا
وبدل جهودا كثيرا لعودتها من زيارات
واجتماعات رفيعه المستوى بعوده سوريا
وبمشاركه عربيه كبيره تنعقد القمه العربيه
الجمعه في السعوديه قمه جده تتطلع الى
البدايه الجديده الى التغيير والتجديد
وتتطلع الى صف واحد وعمل عربي مشترك
ومخرجات تنعكس واقعا سوريا بقضاياها على
راس الجدول اعمال القمه وعلى طاوله البحث
امام القاده والرؤساء العرب توقعات
بمناقشه محاور رئيسيه كعوده البعثه
الدبلوماسيه العربيه الى دمشق وعوده
اللاجئين السوريين الى جانب مناقشه ملفات
اعاده الاعمار وتنميه المش تركه مع الدول
العربيه وعلى طويله القمه العربيه ثانيه
وثلاثين كذلك ملفات وقضايا ساخناك ازمه
السودان والقضيه الفلسطينيه واليمن وليبيا
احنا متفعلين بالخير بعد هالازمه اللي
صارت عندنا 12 سنه وان شاء الله بتعود
سوريا مثل قبل واحسن جانب اقتصادي
اكيد بياثر بصير في ثقه اكبر بالاقتصاد
السوري بيصير في عمليه التداول
مرور ان شاء الله خط النفط من سوريا
بتشتغل عنها العبور الترانزيت للشاحنات
وان شاء الله بتصير الامور تمام تنحل
امورها الشعب وتصير الامور على مثل ما
بتمنى كل واحد فينا
بالجامعه العربيه يعني فاحنا بنشجع وكل
شيء بيقدر يفيدنا تمام لما رجعنا للجامعه
العربيه اللي احنا بنستاهل نكون بهذا
المكان
ان شاء الله نحو الافضل وان شاء الله كل
الامور تنحل وكل ما تقربنا وتقربوا فينا
الدول
افضل
للتقدم افضل
لكل اعمالنا
مشاهدينا نناقش هذا الملف وكل هذه
التفاصيل مع ضيوفنا هنا في الاستوديو فهد
الشجران صحفيه سعودي ومستشار مركز المسبار
للدراسات اهلا بك معنا سيد فهد كذلك من
القاهره دكتور محمد مجاهد الزيات مستشار
المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك من لندن فيس ساره
الكاتب والسياسي السوري اهلا بك سيد فايز
ومن دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام الى هذا النقاش في
الواقع اليوم يقول البعض بانه مشهد تاريخي
تبعناه وسؤال هنا لحضرتك حتى
نؤطر الموضوع معك استاذ مجاهد زياد البعض
يقول بانه المشهد اليوم استثنائي هو مشهد
تاريخي في الواقع وصول بشار الاسد الى
مطار جده
متراسا وفدها المشارك في القمه العربيه ما
الذي يعنيه ليس عوده المقعد فحسب وانما
وصول بش ار الاسد الى جده وتراسه وفده في
هذا في هذه القمه
يعني انا في اعتقادي ان هذا اهم تطور في
الدوره الحاليه للقمه العربيه يعني الزعام
الماضي حاولت الجزائر ان يعني ان تعالج
موضوع المشاركه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه
ومشاركتها في القمه ولم تتمكن لان المناخل
السياسي العربي والدولي لم يكن يسمح بذلك
الاعداد الجيد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
هذه القمه والترتيبات التي تمت قبلها وفرت
المناخ اللازم للتعامل مع الازمه السوريه
والمقاربه التجاهل التام من الجامعه الدول
العربيه وعدم من خيراتها في الازمه تركها
الازمه السوريه في مهب الريح وفي في
اجندات متصارعه اقليميه ودوليه الاعداد
الذي تم خلال هذه القمه والتي توج
بمشاركه الرئيس بشار الاسد في هذه في
جلسات القمه الحاليه يعني ان الجماعه
العربيه قد نجحت
على وشك ان تنجح في ترتيب اتخاذ اليات
مع الازمه السوريه والوصول الى حلول
للامور المستعصيه فيما يتعلق بمستقبلها
ومساراتها طيب ستحدث عن الاليات وبهذا
تكون دكتور ادخلتنا في الواقع في جوهر
الموضوع اليات وتحديات في الواقع نتحدث
عنها وخلينا ندخل في جوهر الموضوع لنفهم
ما هي تحديات عوده سوريا الى مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه استاذ فهد هناك تحديات
سياسيه امنيه وانسانيه وسناتي على تفصيلها
ولكن ما اصعب التحديات بحسب راي حضرتك من
عوده سوريا الى مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه
هناك امرين اثنين اساسيين لابد من التركيز
عليهم اولهما ان عوده سوريا الى القمه
العربيه جاء نتيجه مفاوضات تعتقد بدات من
2016 مع دول الخليج لضروره تثبيت امرين
اثنين اولهما
الحفاظ على ما تبقى من الدوله ومؤسسه
الدوله
الهدف الثاني عدم ترك سوريا باحاضنه
للارهاب البعض يعتقد ان هذه الخطوه هي
خطوه نهائيه وانما مثل ما تفضل الاستاذ
الان النظام السوري او سوريا تواجه تحديات
حقيقيه كانت تغفل عنها او تتناساها او
تتحاشاها بحكم انشغالها بالملف الامني
بشكل شرس من خلال السنوات الماضيه تحدث عن
تحديات الانسانيه مثلا تحديات انسانيه نعم
هناك مشكله اللاجئين طبعا هناك مشكله
كبيره تتعلق مثلا في الاقتصاد والليره
السوريه هناك
تفكك المؤسسات الدوله ما تبقى من مؤسسه
الدوله قويه قليل ولكن
هذا التطبيق او هذه العوده ليست عوده مع
شخص وانما مع دوله هناك فرق بين ان
تطبع مع دوله وبين ان تطبع مع شخص لكن هذا
الشخص هو الذي يقف على سده الدوله نعم
الدول لا تدار بالعواطف او العلاقات
الشخصيه وانما بالمصالح دول الخليج لديها
خطط دمويه البحرين لديها رؤيه سعوديه
لديها رؤيه الامارات لديها رؤيه كل دول
الخليج لديها رؤى اقتصاديه خلال السنوات
القادمه وهي رؤى تحتاج الى الكثير من
الاستقرار الامني على وجه التحديد وكذلك
الاستقرار عدم وجود كلفه في المجتمع في اي
مجتمع عربي راينا كيف تفككت الدوله في
تونس ولكن سرعان ما عاده الامور الى
نصابها كذلك الامر في ليبيا الان الوضع
سيء في السودان الوضع الان جدا سيء ما
تبقى مؤسسات الدوله لا يعد على اصابع اليد
الواحده من بينها الجيش
فهناك فهنا مطامح لعوده هذه العلاقه مع
الدوله في اطار التغير والتحول الاقليمي
من انسحاب امريكا من الشرق الاوسط وصولا
الى الانفتاح الخليجي على الصين
اداره الظهر
او خلينا نقول تراجعها تراجع حضور هذا
موضوع اخر خطير من طالبان طبعا
فضائحي اتيت على ذكر نقطه قلت بانه
السياسه لا تدار بالعواطف الواقع انقل لك
هذه النقطه من لندن سيد فايز ساره سيد
فايز ساره وحضرتك تدافع عن موقف المعارضه
ونحن نتابع في الواقع مواقف المعارضه من
وصول بشار الاسد الى مطار جده ولكن هل
تعتقد بانه هذا الوصول وكما قال منذ قليل
الاستاذ فهد هو يقول بانه في النهايه يجب
ان يكون هناك وتكون هناك عقليه تعامل مع
دوله وليس عقليه تعامل مع شخص حضرتك كيف
تقيم هذه النقطه بالتحديد
يعني اول شيء بدي اقول مساء الخير
لكل المشاهدين
لانه لازم نفتتح هيك حديث
بترحيب بالناس اكثر من انه يعني نبدا يعني
الاشياء العميقه بالموضوع انا بعتقد انه
موضوع القمه العربيه اليوم فيها مستويين
المستوى الاول واللي واللي مستمد من اسم
القمه بانه يبحث الحاله العربي عموما
وبهذا المعنى فان الحاله العربي اليوم
بحاجه الى اجتماع على مستوى القمه لمعالجه
كل التحديات الكبيره اللي عم تصيب العالم
العربي اليوم واللي بيناتها قضايا
الصراعات الداخليه التحديات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه الافق اللي ممكن يصير اله
العالم العربي في الفتره المقبله هاي
مهمات القمه العربيه وانا بعتقد انه اليوم
قمه قمه جده قدام قدام هذا التحدي وخاصه
لما بتكون المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي
اللي عم تستقبل هاي القمه وتعدلها وتجري
هاي التفاعلات هذه الجانب يمكن هو جانب
انا بعتقد انه هو الاساسي لكن هذه الجانب
ما بيكتمل عمليا ولا بيصير
يعني باخذ كل ابعاده الا اذا شفنا الاجزاء
العربيه اللي فيها التهابات كبرى
لالتهابات الكبرى اللي اليوم اخرها
السودان لكن قبل السودان في التهاب سوري
كبير ممتد عبر 13 سنه عبر 13 حوالي 13 سنه
ماضيه هذه الالتهاب تسبب في كثير من
الكوارث الجامعه العربيه والدول العربيه
بتعرف اكثر من اي حدا ثاني مدى الكوارث
اللي يعني ترتبت على
هذه الازمه صحيح تحدثت عن جفاف تحدثت عنه
هو ولكن البعض كذلك استاذ فايز يتحدث عن
ثقه وكيف تقيم في هذه الساعات بين الدول
العربيه وبين سوريا الحاليه استاذ عبد
الحميد اذا وضعنا من صفر العشره حضرتك
تعلم بانه ثقه لا تبنى بين ليله وضح اها
حتى نكون موضوعيين وحتى نكون صراحه كذلك
كان هناك فتره جفاه كبيره بين الطرفين
بحسب رايك حتى يصل بشار الاسد الى مطار
جده وحتى تستلم سوريا مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه نتحدث عن نسبه ثقه كم
للبناء عليها فيما بعد
مساء الخير لك سيدي ريمك الكرام والساده
المشاهدين اعتقد ان القياس في ميزان
الدرجات في السياسه ليس واردا لسبب جوهري
انها انه مطاط
الصفري احيانا يصبح مئه والمئه احيانا
تصبح معدومه بالتالي استطيع القول من
الناحيه الموضوعيه والصريحه كما تفضلتي ان
الذي اوصل الحاله السوريه اليوم الى ما هي
عليه الان في البيت العربي ووصول الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد الى جده لتراس الوفد
السوري في القمه العربيه وما سبقه من
وفوود سوريا
عكست في البدايه هذه الوفود التي سبقت
وصول الرئيس السوري
تغيرا في الخطاب السياسي تجاه
المناخ العربي الحاصل حاليا والعلاقات
العربيه التي تاسست في الاونه الاخيره بعد
اجتماع جده الاول فاجتماع عمان الخماسي
فيوزراء الخارجيه وبالتالي بعد ان وضعت
خارطه الطريق لسوريا وتم تداولها
ومناقشتها مع الجانب السوري لاول مره ربما
في التاريخ العربي يداوون جرحا في البيت
العربي بهذه الصراحه وبهذه الشفافيه
وتشخيص اوجاع سوريه بلا اي مواربه كبتاجون
مخدرات جانب امني جانب سياسي حدود لابد من
ضبطها ثم انتقال لعمليه سياسيه وقرار كذا
ما يتوافق معه هذا التشخيص قدمت معه وصفه
علاج عربيه لهذا الموضوع لو لم يكن هناك
اجوبه سوريه صريحه وواضحه وطمنت الجانب
العربي
على لوكون هناك حاله اوليه للتفاعل مع
الطروحات العربيه اعتقد بان هذه الحاله لم
تكن لتتطور هذا جانب الجانب الاخر اعتقد
بان اليوم العواصم العربيه عموما والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه بثقلها وبوزنها السياسي
والدبلوماسي وبما شهدته من تحولات خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه على كل المستويات
في علاقاتها الدوليه العربيه الاقليميه
وفي وضعها الداخلي باتت اكثر قدره على
تقديمي مثل هذه العلاجات للحاله العربيه
فضلا عن امر اخر اذا سمحت لي بعجاله ان
هناك
مؤشرات على احتمال بروز مشروع عربي في
المنطقه باداره محكمه ومنضبطه تنتمي الى
امكانيات ومقومات ذاتيه للدول الراسخه
اليوم عوده مصر الى ان تتحدث عن العمليه
السياسيه في سوريا اعتقد انه مهم جدا لان
مصر قادره على التاثير تماثلا نظامين
السياسيين في القاهره ودمشق يؤهل القاهره
لتكون ضمن هذه الاسياخ وجود منصه معارضه
في القاهره يؤهل لمثل هذا المناخ ولهذا
السياق ايضا هناك تفهم عربي لكي تكون
المقاربات الخاصه بالعمليه السياسيه في
المرحله الاخيره حتى لا يبدا عمليه
المناكفه
بين الاطراف الداخليه السوريه منذ البدايه
وضعوا اولويه الامن واوضويه واولويه
الانسانيه في اللاجئين والامن لتتقدم على
هذا المشروع واتخذ خطوات
وسنتحدث
استاذ عبد الحميد سنتحدث عن هذه المواضيع
وهذه الملفات المعقده في الواقع ان كانت
الملفات الامنيه او كذلك الملف الانسانيه
وحتى المسار السياسي كيف سيكون ولكن اسمح
لي ان نتحدث فيما مضى على الاقل هناك
عقوبات دول اوروبيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك حتى دول عربيه اوقفت
استثماراتها اوقفت دعمها لسوريا وهنا سؤال
دكتور مجاهد زياد هل تعتقد بانه بعوده
سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه يمكن كذلك
الحديث عن امكانيه التراجع عن هذه
العقوبات
يعني هو الازمه السوريه مركبه ومعقده يعني
العقوبات الدوليه مرتبطه باجنده خاصه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بطبيعه الانتقال
السياسي في سوريا وموقف محدد قاطع من
النظام السياسي الموجود في سوريا ورفضه
هذا موقف متعمد لانه لا يمكن ان تحلل
ازمات السياسيه بوجهات نظر حاده الشكل
ورفض لطبيعه لنظام سياسي موجود داخل
الدوله النقطه الثانيه ان هذه المقاطعه
منعت الاخرين من تقديم المساعدات وتعوق
بصوره كبيره امكانيه البحث عن مجال لعوده
اللاجئين
عطفا على كلام حضرتك دكتور زيات مش حتى
تعيق مساعده الدول العربيه حتى تعرضها
للعقوبات لانه مثلا قانون قيصر
الذي
تقدمت به الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعلى
اثره اصدرت عقوبات في حق النظام السوري
سابقا هذا القانون يجرم ك ذلك بعض الدول
التي يمكن ان تتعاقد مع سوريا تفضل فقط
عطفا على كلام حضرتك وتاكيدا عليه
تمام لكن اعتقد ان هناك بدايه نوع من
التغيير في الموقف الامريكي ملامحه كانت
واضحه عندما تحدثت امريكا انها ترفض
التقارب والتطبيع العربي لكنها تتفاهم
وهذا جديد النقطه الثانيه في تجديد الرئيس
بايدن للقانون
للمقاطعه لسوريا تحدث عن ربطها بامكان
تحقيق تقدم في العمليه السياسيه ربما في
تصوري لو نجحت القمه العربيه في احداث
مقاربه جيده وتفاهمات مع الرئيس بشار
الاسد والحكومه السوريه يعني ما حدث حتى
الان هو النقطه الاولى هي البدايه اعتقد
كما قال الزميل من دمشق ان هناك حوارا جرى
بالتاكيد وطرحت فيه كل القضايا الشائكه
وكل المطالب التي تطلبها الدول العربيه
والدول الاخرى وهي خاصه بالانتقال السياسي
وطبيعته وتتعلق بملف امني يعتقد بامور
كثيره لكن من بينها الافراج عن معتقلين
نوع من الانفراج الداخليه ربما لو حدث مثل
هذا التقدم يكون مبررا لموقف امريكي مختلف
او تاجيل او تجميد للعقوبات لفتره يمكن ان
تدفعنا الى مرحله ثانيه اذا الازمه
السوريه تحتاج الى عمل مرحلي لو انجز
العرب في جامعتهم تقدما في هذا المستوى
وتجاوبت الحكومه السوريه معه في المرحله
الاولى ربما يكون لدينا مبادره للبناء
عليها خلال المرحله التاليه طيب يبقى
السؤال هل نتحدث عن عمل عربي مشترك هل
نتحدث عن توجه عربي مشترك او يمكن ان
تتخلف دوله
مجموعه من الدول عن هذا العمل لماذا اطرح
هذا السؤال لانه السفير احمد ابو الغيط
كان ذكر في اكثر من مناسبه بانه ليس هناك
الزام من الجامعه العربيه للتطبيع الكامل
مع سوريا سنتذكر هذا التصريح مشاهدينا
وكذلك ضيوفنا الكرام حين قال بانه لا يمكن
او لا نلزم كل دوله
بتطبيع كامل مع سوريا ومن ثم نعود
لاستكمال هذا النقاش النهارده سوريا
عضو كامل العضويه له كل الصلاحيات وكل
الحقوق وكل الواجبات على
الدوله العطر
طبعا هذه العوده
لا تفرض على الدول اعضاء الجامعه نهجم
معين تجاه
الحكومه السوريه هي عاده
بتوافق من الجميع
هناك من سوف يعيد علاقات وهناك من سوف
يتحفظ في اعاده العلاقات هذا امر خاص
بزياده كل دوله لكن عضويتها كامله واعتقد
انها
سببت
غضب لدى اعداء الحكم في سوريا في العالم
الغربي اساسا
الى نقاش سيد فهد لما يقول للسفير احمد
ابو الغيط ليس هناك لا نلزم بمنهج موحد
لدول العربيه للتعاطي مع سوريا الحاليه ما
الذي يعني ذلك بالتاكيد هناك خلافات شديده
حول موضوع التطبيع مع سوريا في هذه القمه
وهي خلافات ممتده لها اكثر من سنتين حول
هل يحضر السد او لا يحضر الاسد ولكن الان
الدول العربيه يعني بدات تدرك خاصه بعد
زلزال سوريا والدمار الانسانيه المخيفه
الذي حدث ان عزله النظام بهذه الطريقه لا
يمكن السكوت عنها والدول العربيه على
مستويات في علاقته بعضها لم تنقطع علاقتهم
مع النظام من الاساس وبعضها الاخر انقطعت
علاقته ثم اعادها والبعض الاخر اعادها
اليوم اعادها الان
وهناك تفاوت هناك نظريات متطرفه ضد النظام
السوري او ضد بشار الاسد ولكن ايضا هناك
نظريات تتفهم لانه امر واقع هناك من
الربيع العربي ما سمي بالرب العربي هناك
نظريتين نظريه كارثيه تقول لابد من اسقاط
النظام الايراني واسقاط النظام السوري
واسقاط وهذه وهذه نظريات غير غير واقعيه
وهذه تعيق مستويات التنميه وهي تسبب كلفه
على دول الخليج لانها هي المعنيه اكبر
داعم للعالم العربي او الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه هي دول الخليج لا تريد ان
تتحمل اعباء الاخرين او عباء
معارك ستنتهي الا ان يفني احدهما الاخر
ليس لها نهايه وليس لها افق وبالتالي لابد
من طرح مساله الحوار وللتتذكر ان دول
الخليج وعلى راسها السعوديه طرحت مساله
التسويه السياسيه منذ زمن طويل ولكن للاسف
لم تكن هناك الظروف مواتيه وايضا لم تكن
وجهات النظر متقاربه لكن بالحوار والتفاهم
يمكن بناء اسس
يلبيها النظام السوري الخليج والعالم
العربي وايضا تمكين هذا النظام
بدء ادراك ازماته الصحيحه لينظر الى وجهه
بالمراه هناك ازمات ليست مزحه الان ليس
هذه القمه ليست بلسما له وانما هي وضعه
امام مشكلاته وتحدياته ان كان قادرا على
ان ينهي هذه الازمات الانساني منها او
الامني سواء الامني على مستويين هناك دول
الخليج تعاني من تهريب المخدرات من سوريا
وهي كارثه الان يعني بما يشبه الحرب الان
بين دول الخليج وعصابات تهريب المخدرات
الجانب الثاني وهو الارهاب الارهاب الذي
يضم فصائل شيعيه وسنيه تتقاتل فيما بينها
وايضا تساهم في بلبله الامن في دول الخليج
التي لا تريد لهذا النظام لدوله ان تسقط
بغيت الحفاظ على ما تبقى من مؤسسات الدوله
وصد الاذى وصد الشر بما يمكن خاصه اننا
ليست لديها حدود مع دول الخليج حتى يكون
يكون لديها ذلك الاهتمام العالي وانما
ايضا له جانبه الانساني ونحن نعلم ان
القوه الاغاثيه التي حدثت بعد زلزال كانت
اكبرها من دول الخليج وتحديدا من السعوديه
والامارات وهذا جانب ايضا انساني يتوازى
مع ضروره حل الحل السياسي لبدايه حل
الازمات الانسانيه داخل المجتمع السوري
ونحن سنعود
ومؤسساتها بالفعل ونحن سنعود للحديث عن
عوده اللاجئين سنعود للحديث عن الوضع
الانساني وسنعود كذلك للحديث عن التحديات
السياسيه ايضا التي يمكن ان تترتب او ان
تتسبب فيها هذه الازمه في كل الحالات
سنذهب الى فاصل مشاهدينا نعود من بعده
لنتابع دائما في اطار نفس هذا الموضوع
اكتمل النصاب وعدد سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه بيد من تسويه ازماتها رئيس الاسد
ام المجتمع الدولي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات